they arrived and they entered week near where
they took them and rural carlos I am
while another ball of pastel candles
people turned off the opportunity to be
everything with elton john in process
every day never biliary
they will disappear
I was dedicated to one of the intentions
is to look for women
let's go out together to paint let's go out together
to demand that they let us live
we play together to sue later the
human rights and all these struggles
which are in process by the
women
if he does not respect the life that
that question the murder the torture
the violence
the man keep remembering what
that have not been resolved with cases or
things and that you can
proposing organizing and creating
these alternative ways to pose
other worlds different issues
your love where he embodied the union in
conversation of the absurd